hi i'm bailey i started working at biv
and pearce and associates in gore
through the close the gaps program part
of this closing the gaps has enabled us
to keep
local people who would normally head off
to the big cities for these type of jobs
especially an accounting job
this way they've come back to gore they
want to stay and gore and training or so
it's fantastic it's been really cool to
come back home to a small town and work
with quite a close office firstly and
then also with
your clients you get to know and
yeah it's quite cool to be
personal level with them i like finance
i like numbers but yeah working with
clients in in an office is something
i've always wanted to do
with this grant assists us with the
existing staff we've got helping the
system with their training for their
professional development
and
we'll get some decent accountants at the
other end of it so we're more than happy
it takes a lot to step from a classroom
into a job and
without being given that training and
on-site experience there's just like you
can continue doing more courses but it's
been a lot faster and beneficial for us
to be able to just do it on site we're
also looking into studying on further
and becoming chartered accountants which
it's a bit of a bigger step in another
couple of years of study and while
you're working and get the experience
too and it's a great initiative to keep
young people in gore